[Musica]
partirei come un aneddoto un aneddoto
che serve per definire due momenti della
mia vita io cerca nel del cavallo del 93
mila nel centro dell'alta 3 il negozio
mi entro una signora mettono a signora
molto modesta tranquilla e mi misi con
molta tranquillità signor fabbri sono
molto prendere un suo panettone l'ho
assaggiato da una mia amica
l'ho trovato molto buono e lo devo
regalare al mio dottore so che a lui
piacciono le cose buone che vorrei
fargli questo regalo grazie molto
gentile sto per prendere il panettone e
mi dice sai io so che il suo panettone
questo un po di più degli altri
io prendo la pensione minima però io
sono convinta che per il mio dottore
faccio bella figura
gli dissi grassi molto gentile l'altro a
temi si stringe un po il cuore però è
anche lo stomaco di yen avrei regalato
se l'era per l'imbarazzo che mettevo la
signora e io dissi tranquillamente ma
signora mi fa piacere magari le posso
offrire un certosino ormai a riad a
farle assaggiare perché se lei piace
alle cose buone mi piacerebbe farli
assaggiare un certosino volentieri
insomma destini non bastava questa
signora sempre molto garbatamente una
persona solo come certe persone ti sanno
guardare qui ora diviso per falsa signor
fabbri
io sono nata con un grosso difetto
io guardavo la signora
non mi sembrava avesse difetto la
signora sui quali difetto signora se
posso azzardare io sono andata con un
attimo l'ottimo palato cavolo
guardate io avevo già lavorato quasi 30
anni
questa per me fu una lezione di vita
un'esternazione pazzesca perché perché
quando mi disse questo io feci mente
locale ed essi questo chi nasce con un
buon palato non è una dote una sfortuna
perché a volte possono essere fortuna di
chi ha soldi o no questa è una dote che
uno ce l'ha con non c'era questa
esternazione mi ha fatto riflettere
sulla scelta del mio lavoro ed alla mia
filosofia di vita professionale
avevo già lavorato quasi 30 anni però
probabilmente avevo diciamo così
indirizzato diversamente il mio lavoro
avevo iniziato a lavorare con delle
materie prime buonissime negli anni 60
poi abbiamo siamo caduti dentro diciamo
così a quel vortice del consumismo
lavorando semilavorati lavorando altri
prodotti vari però mi presento adesso io
sono gino fabbri faccio il pasticcere o
negozi e bologna in via cadriano o
natività dove c'è lavoro a mia moglie e
le mie due figlie e valérie e viviana
condividiamo questa esperienza
io ho iniziato l'attività nel 64 poi
come dicevo prima
abbiamo lavorato continuamente fino al
93 dal 93 in poi abbiamo cambiato un po
tutta la filosofia di lavoro abbiamo
preferito fare una scelta che ci ri
convertisse completamente il lavoro che
nell'andare né verso il futuro verso il
moderno non abbiamo fatto altro che
riprendere
abitudine quelli di lavorare le materie
prime più giuste ho partecipato a
diversi concorsi
ho vinto il concorso del giubileo nel
1999 ho avuto l'udienza papale nel 2000
nel 13 dicembre del 2000 con papa
wojtyla e l'io è stata un'esperienza
veramente molto importante perché con
l'udienza papale ti danno anche le
chiavi di san pietro durante l'udienza
papale e la basilica è chiusa e quando
ti consegna delle chiavi di san pietro e
si entra in san pietro fede o non fede
però quando uno vede la pietà di
michelangelo capisce che davanti a un
esempio di perfezione più totale e
abbiamo gradito queste tre quarti d'ora
io e mia moglie dentro la basilica
proprio davanti e delle incredibili
realtà bellissima veramente molto bella
quando siamo usciti
eravamo ancora più convinti di
perseguire questo tipo di filosofia
ho partecipato ad altri concorsi non li
sto a dire per il tanto non serve a
nulla fino a che non ho fatto quello del
2015 vincendo a lione la coppa del mondo
da lì in poi vabbè c'è poco da dire che
cosa debbo dire che dagli anni 70 fino
al 90 abbiamo utilizzato poco della
nostra professione se non per utilizzare
quello che gli conveniva alle aziende di
darci dei semilavorati dei surrogati le
margarine e cieli dicevano pure che
erano buoni a ci dicevano pure che
andava tutto bene ma non avevamo inter
non avevamo conoscenza del ramo scuole
non avevamo assolutamente nulla
dopo di che da quando abbiamo fatto
questa riconversione invece mi sono
avvicinato a quei prodotti della natura
che d'altura ci offre il bureau ce lo
offre la natura il latte arriva dalla
natura arrivano tutto arriva tutto le
abbiamo tutto forse fuori casa
perché io sono nato contadino io sono
altro contadino e quando da bambino ero
contadino
devo dire che forse mi sentivo anche di
serie b da bambino perché in campagna
quando andavi in c paese ti sembrava di
essere un un bambino di ultimo tipo
d'arme di ultimo livello
poi quando ho iniziato a lavorare invece
ho capito tante cose che avevo capito
che cosa significava la frutta buon
davvero dura buona la carne buona certi
valori
perché io sono nato in una famiglia dove
avevo i nonni gli zii i genitori perciò
una famiglia chiamiamola allargata
questo mi è servito molto nella vita mi
ha servito sicuramente tanto e che cosa
debbo dire quando noi abbiamo fatto
questa scelta di lavorare un'altra volta
con prodotti della natura trovarsi di
fronte a delle aziende che invece ti
hanno ostacolato che hanno dato contro
perché perché c'era degli interessi di
mezzo però ho continuato con la mia
scelta professionale
la mia scelta professionale nella
portata avanti fino al giorno d'oggi e
non dico che sia vincente tanto io non
sono mai arrivato vai nel nostro lavoro
dire che siamo arrivati
volevo semplicemente dire che noi con i
prodotti che abbiamo in italia possiamo
dominare il mondo
solo che non ne siamo coscienti perché
perché abbiamo la miglior frutta secca
del mondo perchè abbiamo i migliori
agrumi del mondo se non avevamo la
ricotta e la prima scarpone non avremmo
vinto dei campionati del mondo se non
avessimo il marsala non avremo lo
zabaione
abbiamo dei prodotti che noi solo noi
possiamo dire che li abbiamo e l'italia
nel mondo sa fare e sa dire qualche cosa
che cosa significa avere la possibilità
di quel palazzo di quella signora
riconoscere con i cinque sensi che
abbiamo quello che abbiamo oggi
perché se vediamo un bel dolce un bel
cibo lo sappiamo distinguere naso perché
se abbiamo un buon olfatto lo riusciamo
a distinguere un dito perché l'udito
perché se mangiamo una meringa ci
riusciamo a distinguere con l'udito un
croccante una pasta frolla abbiamo il
palato riparato da incredibile fucina di
messaggi al cervello
se accendiamo il cervello riusciamo a
fare una degustazione incredibile
abbiamo addirittura il retrogusto perché
se mangiamo una meringa al limone
addirittura noi abbiamo la possibilità
di avere all'i ndietro quel retrogusto
quel profumo del limone perché l'olio
essenziale dell'imo dicitore dall
indietro
che cosa ci manca nulla noi d'archi dai
chinotti al mandarini dal bergamotto a
al l'imu ai limoni le moli di alfie
limoni di sorrento li del bardello della
sicilia pistacchi di bronte che cosa ci
manca nulla non ci mancherebbe nulla
però con questi prodotti dobbiamo fare
delle ricette che cos'è una ricetta una
ricetta non è altro che una filosofia di
lavoro di persone
la ricetta non la faccio io io posso
avere un'idea ma se l'idea non è
condivisa dal resto dell'equipe non
significa assolutamente nulla serve un
confronto e il confronto io ce l'ho
quando mi metto in discussione
discussione confronto con delle persone
metto posto non c'è mai nessuna ricetta
sbagliata la ricetta mai buttarla la
ricetta si mette in un cassetto
poi si va a togliere un'altra volta dopo
due mesi dopo cinque mesi o un dolce in
un negozio che si chiama prezioso
ci ho messo tre anni prima di metterle
in vendita perciò ci vuole del tempo ma
prima o poi arriva l'idea giusta
la ricetta bisogna pensarla cominciare a
provarla confrontarsi col resto
dell'equipe da soli non si vince in
equipe sia abbiamo visto dai con fori
nei concorsi e l'abbiamo visto nelle
aziende l'abbiamo visto dal
sulla nostra pelle e la ricetta è la
stessa identica cosa
la ricetta è condivisione perché perché
comunque il cibo è condivisione il cibo
e affetto quando la palla con una
giornalista mi chiese una volta qual era
il mio dolce preferito pensi che io
dissi la ciambella casalinga come la
ciambella casalinga si sembra la
casalegno mi ricorda gli affetti da
bambino però è anche quella che la posso
mangiare alla mattina con latte alla
sera col vino dolce ed è sempre buona
vedete una mousse al cioccolato bella
finchè vuoi tecnicamente perfetta però
se la maggio oggi e domani non è che mi
viene voglia di ri mangiarlo alla
ciambella sì ecco quello il buono questo
sì che io prendo sempre di riferimento
questo secondo il mio punto di vista è
la ricetta è un percorso di confronto e
un percorso di utilizzo di materie prime
e sapere come amalgamarle le materie
prime che noi in italia li abbiamo
queste possibilità
fatto questo discorso qua vi volevo
semplicemente dire che secondo il mio
punto di vista l'italia può farcela
anche nel nostro settore tranquillamente
io lo vedo bene il mio futuro
sicuramente lo vedo nella mia famiglia
lo vedono ai miei figli alla mia figlia
che cos'è e cercare di dare la
possibilità a loro quello che non
abbiamo fatto noi perché noi abbiamo
utilizzato dei gli strumenti non molto
adatti
adesso quel cos'è il futuro utilizzare
materiali nuovi che sono quelli che sono
sostenibili
abbiamo la necessità di gestire il
futuro con il packaging giusto con degli
strumenti giusti con dei prodotti giusti
e l'esasperazione del naturale a volte è
quello più dannoso in assoluto perché
l'esasperazione no va bene da nessuna
parte
non cerchiamo di cercherà di andare
incontro al super biologico perché
significa mettere a repentaglio altre
risorse della terra
perciò bisogna avere un equilibrio anche
lì io mi auguro che le mie figlie e
tutti quello che quelli dell'accademia
maestri pasticceri dove io sono
presidente
possono seguire questa linea i giovani
sarà nel nostro futuro
io lo spero veramente anzi non solo
io ci credo
[Applauso]